i didn't picture you as a met gala kind
of person
what is the medcast i don't even know
what that is what is that nonsense what
is it
it's cr it's nuts it's
what is famous it's famous people famous
peopleing that's what it is right
and the idea is that if you go to the
met gala you wear a designer outfit and
you and oscar de la renta said
billy we want you to wear our outfit and
you said i'll tell you what i'll wear
your outfit if you stop using fur
and they stopped using fur i liked it
i think that was great i'm i'm really
happy you did it so you wore this gown
and you go to the met gal and what did
you who did you meet there other famous
people
yeah i mean anybody cool
yeah everybody cool i mean [ __ ] i
hear billy and turn around frank ocean i
mean the [ __ ] is that you know what the
[ __ ] is he doing there he's frank ocean
yeah what is it then you you look around
and it's like oh kid cudi and then oh uh
you know
everybody else
it's you know what i i the main thing
that night made me think
or feel was
how
famous people are just like literally
nobodies i mean just nobodies just
randos and it's so
weird and i i mean i was like wow all
these people are just somebody that's in
class with you you know and you think
this person's kind of annoying you
really like this person you get along
with this person and
everybody's just like
embarrassed and insecure about what
they're doing and saying and
i mean it was amazing though it was a
beautiful like it just was beautiful in
there and
you know what's nice about other people
that are in the same kind of
world that you're in is they're
they're not getting their phone out and
shoving it in your face because they
don't want that themselves and that is
really relieving because that that's the
that's that's my problem with the world
is is no matter what's going on or where
you are there's
just just people shove
that phone in your face and it's it's
really
you know it's a disaster
yeah i have a real i hate it with the
phones uh you know because this is all i
see
this is what i see
people who are sneaky sneaking the phone
up to to take a picture of you now i i
hate the way i look
and when someone takes that phone out to
take a picture of me
i sit there and i go i don't want
another horrible picture of me out there
it suppresses me because i i see it i i
hate it if i was good looking to snap
away who gives a [ __ ] if i look like
john stamos i'd be like go ahead take a
picture it's the best thing the way you
look howard i love you oh my god i love
the way you look
well you got an iconic face
yeah that's that's the way of looking at
it i guess
you